dan what about the writer that's
Toulouse - sloppy doesn't totally check
everything out oh it's going to be fine
because there's they're almost like two
of the same two sides of the same coin
mm-hmm well that's where a consultant
like me can really help you know can
really tell you okay this is not a
professional level quality there I was
confused and in places I really felt
like scenes went on way too long I felt
like these voices weren't authentic and
dialogue so I'm the kind of person a
writing coach a story consultant who can
really help someone like that and really
guide them to improve their craft so
both of those traits perfectionist loose
kind of non detail-oriented where does
that stem from where where does it stem
from where you fall on the spectrum now
I'm wondering how does someone become a
perfectionist and how does somebody
become kind of loose you know sort of
kind of lazy lazy writer I'm not even
sure if it's lazy but they don't seem to
care as much about details because I
think they don't matter mm-hmm maybe
they're willing to spend time on stuff
that does matter
so they're not lazy in that respect but
in terms of tying up loose ends they
think that they'll understand you know
there's just some people that flow with
certain things in one way and are more
controlled in other ways and where does
that where does that come from well I
think it comes from your personality and
I think it comes from your own personal
experience how you approach creative
work but it is a craft and it's gonna
take a long time to learn that craft and
to really perfect it and to write your
best work to find your voice and write
the best thing that you were born to
write it's gonna take time and if you
are really loose and what you might call
lazy just you're not detail-oriented
you're not specific you don't care if if
the scene is confusing because it makes
sense to you well that's gonna be a
problem because the reader cares because
the reader wants it to make sense and
wants it to be tight and wants it to
have a really great arc and surprise and
some
their expectations and wants it to just
be great
so if you are a really loose writer than
maybe screenwriting is not quite the
discipline for you then the flip side of
one that can't let it go because there's
just too many variables that they've got
to make sure right but then it the life
is squeezed out because it's so it's so
tight it can become drier the more you
pick at it and pick at it you know I
can't say specifically which draft you
know does that happen like okay between
draft twelve and fifteen it's gonna get
way too dry and you're gonna lose that
original essence you know but there is
that instance in which someone picks at
something and picks at something
rewrites it so many times takes every
single note they get from every friend
and every consultant and it ends up just
kind of bleeding it dry and you lose the
essence of the original idea the
original concept you know what made you
passionate about that so that's a that's
a pitfall to to look out for you know
you